m
[Silence]
sh
I'm
[Silence]
for
we are
continuing our class our reading
of some chapters from the
book this is a book authored
by may Allah have mercy upon him and the
scholars of
Islam
and this is one of the
references
that used in authoring his
book which is the book that we've been
studying
for well because of covid I mean we
started it before covid but because of
covid it's been
about 5 years that we've been reading in
z
it's a lengthy book and we've tried
to cover a lot of ground we've
gotten a little bit past the halfway
point and
some of
because wrote this
book
he wrote it from
memory so because of that memory
obviously is is not going to be as
orderly and it's not going to be as
thorough as something which
is written and compiled in in a library
he was traveling and he wrote it from
memory so because of that there are some
aspects which he just kind of goes
through very quickly just touches upon
and other aspects where he goes into
depth so because of that we tried to use
some of the original texts and
references that he used in compiling his
book because that's essentially
what was trying to do when he authored
the
book We are continuing in the Miracles
of the Prophet Sall alai
wasam last week we stopped at the
mention of Y and
Ma
[Silence]
tur
last week we stopped at
the mention of the battles that would
ensue between the Muslims and the Turk
Turk here doesn't mean they're from
turkey and unfortunately it has been
translated that way in some books some
books that have tried to translate some
of the narrations of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam they
Translate
his narrations regarding the battles
between the tur and other narrations
where he dis praises the Turk and they
took it to mean people that are Turkish
people that are from Turkey this is not
at all what's intended he described
at tur and he said they have very small
beady eyes very wide faces and very
flat noses this is obviously a mention
of
the mongrels
of Asia and what happened and ensued in
the years of fighting the tartars
with genas Khan who began that kind
of shen and then his Generations his
offspring his Prodigy continued on after
him and car carried that on there was a
number of reasons why these wars happen
they were bound to
happen yes there was a lot of
influence
from Bad
intelligence that the Khalifa at the
time in Iraq was
given he made a very bad decision a
couple of bad
decisions and one of the worst decisions
he made
was his advisor that he listened to his
advisor that he listened to was a known
ra is an A type of shiaism that is very
extreme to the point that it takes often
takes its followers out of the fold of
Islam and he had a lot of
buried ranker for the Muslims and so he
advised him with every piece of advice
that he could that would get the Muslims
into a bloodbath War situation with
the Tartar and this is what happened
this is what
ensued and there's a silver lining
around every dark cloud as Allah subhah
wa taala has designed This
World by his mercy and
we see that the effects of that were
negative
immediately but the effects of that
war and that
destruction
later were a root cause for a Revival of
many of Islamic Sciences scholarship
authors there was a huge influx
of people who who traveled to the Muslim
world and became Muslim
including the mongrels himself
themselves they later became Muslim his
grandson gas Khan's grandson later
accepted
[Silence]
Islam irq
can Al wasam Another prophecy of his of
our Prophet Muhammad s.
wasam that he prophesied to his
companions prophesized prophesied both
are
correct was
that Yemen would become a Muslim country
would become a Muslim land its people
would become Muslim and the Muslims
would rule in Yemen likewise AEM AEM at
the time was following the religion
they were mainly Christian and they
were governed by the Roman Empire at the
time
likewise was mainly governed by
the by the Persians at the time because
the Romans and the Persians in the time
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
they were constantly clashing they were
the two superpowers in the world at that
time the Arab world was kind of in the
middle and where it got too hot and too
intense meaning the the weather itself
you can't just March out into the desert
with an army and so it became almost
impenetrable because of that and not
just that but there was no point in
going to the desert and conquering the
desert there just nothing out there
the cabba was
there the
the Caba later Medina at the time it
was ye it wasn't the prophet sallallah
alam's City and it was for the most part
left
alone it was for the most part left
alone and so during the time of the
Prophet s. wasam he informed and Yemen
was also Christian at the time it was
mainly Christians some Jews and they
were mainly governed by Arab tribes
and a large portion of Yemen was in
conflict and under the governance of
the the
habash the
Ethiopian Kingdom at the time which
was a Christian kingdom the prophet
sallallah
wasam prophesies
that all three of these places will
become lands of the Muslims and the
Muslim empire would
conquer the lands of Yemen the lands of
asem which would be you know Philistine
Jordan Lebanon Syria these areas
parts of
turkey parts of Iraq that is Islam would
spread to these places and they would
become part of the Muslim Empire's
territories
likewise and so it came to pass he also
informed that the Muslim empire would
have three major
strongholds that would grip the entire
Known World at the time with regards to
military militar
and that is they would have a major
military in
Hashem they would have a major military
in Iraq they would have a major military
in Yemen and so it came to pass so much
so that the
books most accurate with regards
to
so if we think about
this we can we can see what history is
not just based on what people say it was
at the time we can also gauge what
history
is based on what those
people held as their values and what
they spoke about the most right so for
instance inesem and Yemen these became
the very strong they were strongholds
and great Muslim armies were there the
people of Yemen and the people of Hashem
were known for their
military and they were basically the two
major branches of the Muslim Empire's
military generations of Muslims grew up
Soldiers the son of soldiers the son of
soldiers the son of soldiers Generations
upon
generations and in that kind of climate
we can look at the scholars of ashem for
instance the scholars of Yemen during
that Aon we see that they were most
proficient in the aspects of the Prophet
Sall alaih wasallam Sunnah which have to
do with war and defense and offense and
Military and so forth so for instance
alaz books that are written regarding
the campaigns and the battles that the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam was
involved in or that he was involved
in directly or indirectly we see that
the most proficient Scholars of the Sala
were those from AEM they had detailed
and recorded and pined over this aspect
of the Prophet Sall alai wasallam Sunnah
in Yemen Hadith in
it was
the Quran the scholars there were
most proficient in that and this
is an indicator of what the environment
was at the time so this Prophecy of
the Prophet sallallah wasam where he
tells us that the great branches of the
Muslim Empire's military will be in
Yemen and in a
and in Iraq and we see that it was
so it permeated the region and the
people's minds so much so that even
their Scholars even from an Islamic
standpoint that that is where the best
Works were written and comprised on
the aspect of
jihad he
says
[Silence]
another prophecy was that Egypt would be
conquered by the Muslims and this
happened all of these things happened in
the time of the
companions all of these regions were
conquered by the time
of by the time of AR
men Egypt was
conquered
by the conquest of
Egypt
was something that even the older
companions were involved in this is how
swiftly these things occurred such
as Who led many of the campaigns that
set the foundations for that Conquest
the prophet sallallah alai wasam
mentioned that he described the land of
Egypt and he said to his
companions
[Silence]
wasam
be
forer
[Silence]
that
for
[Silence]
sh
m
[Silence]
and
we
have narrations that the prophet s.
wasam spoke about the conquest of
Egypt these are authentic
narrations and one of
the one of
the virtues of Egypt and its people was
that the prophet s.
wasam advised his companions that when
you take the Reigns in Egypt that you
are to be good and kind to its
people for they have an affiliation a
familial tie to us and that is
that due to the fact that
ha which is ibraim concubine the mother
of
isma she was from Egypt
and likewise the prophet Muhammad s.
wasam his concubine as well Maria the
mother of his child so there is a
familial
relation by law and so the prophet
Sall wasam commanded the companions to
be good to its people in fulfilling
their obligations towards them and there
are other narrations with regards to the
virtues of
Egypt many of them are
inauthentic but we look at the Quran and
we see that Allah subhanahu waala tells
us one of the greatest stories or most
of the greatest stories in the Quran
that were
most
concentrated took place in Egypt with
with with M with the pharaoh of Egypt
known as the Pharaoh of Moses likewise
the story of
Yousef and the governance there in Egypt
and so this is enough of a virtue as for
narrations this doesn't take away from
the virtue of a of a place or people
when we say this narration here is
inauthentic what we mean is from the
aspect of the science of
Hadith narrations have a
strict set of criteria that they have to
meet in order to
be considered the words of the Prophet
s.
was
[Silence]
am
can
[Silence]
for
subh
[Silence]
sh
was
[Silence]
will
for
[Silence]
all
another
prophecy
was that the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam informed of a man known as a
his name was
a
and he is known
as
and may Allah be pleased with him
[Silence]
so Al was a man from Yemen and he had
leprosy he was a leper and
leprosy throughout history I mean till
today leprosy is a scary thing it's just
that we've been able to subdue it to an
extent to where it's almost eradicated
from the earth
almost and that's a type of bacteria and
we have we have things to treat it but
leprosy throughout history has been a
very terrifying thing people didn't know
how
leprosy
was passed on they didn't understand how
leprosy was
transmitted and it was terrifying it
literally rots
your your your limbs off the nose the
fingers wherever the blood circulates
the least it just eats it away until a
person is deformed
permanently and so it's something very
scary and
people were very wary of leprosy and
this is why
we see the significance
of that one of his most mentioned
Miracles was that he was able to cure
the leper by the will of
Allah curing the leper and raising the
Dead one and the same thing back
then it had never been seen it's it's
that someone would be relieved of
leprosy if you have leprosy it's
basically death sentence people were so
terrified of it that a leper would
become totally abandoned by the entire
city by his family he he it it's a very
terrible
end
Al was afflicted with
Leprosy and he made Dua to Allah
subhanal that he cure
him that he keep this leprosy at Bay and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did
so
by pushing all of the leprosy out of his
body except for a spot that was left
about the size of a gold coin on one of
his
feet
and was a Muslim in the time of the
Prophet s.
wasam he was a Muslim from when he first
heard
of the Prophet s. wasam and that was the
one of the first
places that Islam was spread after the
Arab peninsula was Yemen Yemen was
called to Islam and the people of Yemen
were called to Islam in the time of the
Prophet s. wasam he sent Abu he
sent and they spent time there teaching
people and the people people of Yemen
accepted Islam the last Gran of
disbelief that came from some of the
people of Yemen was that of mus
mus
alab was also from Yemen and after his
after he was dispatched by the armies
of Islam the armies of Abu
Bakr Yemen has been a stronghold of
Islam ever since
and believed in the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam from the
beginning when he was called to Islam he
answered the call and he became one of
the most upstanding and
outstanding
Muslims comparable to the companions
and so when he made this
Dua that Allah subhanahu waala cure his
leprosy that Allah subhanahu wa taala
reduced it it was reduced and this was
considered a miracle and this is
considered one of the Miracles of the
Prophet sallallah alai
wasam however he did not travel to meet
the prophet sallallah alai because he
had an ailing mother she was fully
dependent on him
and he was the only one that looked
after her and took care of her so if he
was to leave her to go and meet the
prophet s. wasam he would be
forsaking his duty to his mother and
so
he made the decision not to do that and
he was only able to travel after his
mother had passed away but subsequently
after the prophet himself had passed
away and so he is referred to as
a is a type of person that was a
contemporary of the Prophet Muhammad s.
wasam but never met him as a
Muslim the prophet s. wasam informed
Omar that you will meet a
man whose name is a he is the narration
is inah
Muslim and he had leprosy and Allah
cured his
leprosy and reduced it to the size of a
gold
coin when you meet
him ask that he make or seek
forgiveness on your
behalf and so the fact that the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam is advising Omar
to ask way to make Dua for him this is
an incredible honor and this articulates
the high
esteem
that held in the sight of Allah subah
Waal and his
messenger was a man who was very
simple and he was a man who refused the
spotlight
and part of his refusal of the spotlight
was that he would not tell people who he
was because he heard of the narration of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he came to Medina with the soldiers
of Yemen they were at that time going up
to aam and going up to Iraq to fight the
empires of Persia and
Rome and he came with the groups and
the militaries that were sent from
Yemen and when Omar realized who he was
he honored him and
he you know he was very kind to him
and very honoring of him obviously
because the prophet himself sallallahu
alaihi wasallam told him to
be and when word spread in Medina as of
who way was he left
Medina
Omar offered to him
to tell the people of Iraq his
Governor there to take care of him and
he completely refused this
idea and he practically begged Omar not
to inform his governors in Iraq that
he would be
coming but as things
go when o
reached
to over time people who recognized him
from the company of Omar recognized that
that
is who the prophet
sallam
mentioned so he became a celebrity a
super mega celebrity amongst the
Muslims you know basically
overnight and he disappeared from
Iraq avoiding that Spotlight and that
is the sunset of his
story The Prophet
Sall prophesized of his
existence during his time he prophesized
of the miracle that Allah subhanahu wa
taal had granted him he prophesized that
he would meet Omar and all of those
things things came to
pass we will stop there tonight insh
until next
[Silence]
week
sh